deputy prime minister's with us now good
morning thank you for joining us on the
program um tori slees
how long have you personally known chris
pincher was an alleged sex pest
well that's a very generic term what's
the specific question um
i've obviously seen the most recent
uh uh reports he's stepped down as a
minister he's had the whip withdrawn i
think the reports are very serious they
deserve to be independently investigated
that's what will now happen under the
parliamentary grievance process i think
we need to respect that i think the
integrity of the system is very
important for me the most important
thing is that
anyone who's got a complaint of this
kind of severity must feel confident and
comfortable in coming forward what
exactly did you know about his behavior
well
that's true so but there's always
reports and rumors swirling around
westminster it's that kind of place you
know that and uh lots of these things uh
don't materialize um and and actually
having worked with chris pincher um i
always found him on the whole uh very
professional but as there's a reporter
about a complaint that was made at the
foreign office i'm sure you're poised to
ask me about that and we dealt with that
in the most rigorous and robust way
i'll do the questions you do the answers
2019 he was working for you were you
completely comfortable uh with uh being
his boss when these sort of allegations
were being leveled against him well just
to be clear because that's a specific
question i'll give you a very clear
answer there was a complaint uh made by
someone that worked with him about
inappropriate behaviour i swiftly agreed
with the permanent secretary says simon
mcdonald at the time that that ought to
be reviewed under the civil services
auspices to make sure it was done
without fear or favor it came back and
uh did not recommend
formal disciplinary action and it should
be said that the individual made the
complaint did not want that um i spoke
to chris pincher about the inappropriate
behaviour made it clear in no uncertain
terms it should desist it must never be
repeated so did the permanent secretary
for additional assurance because i take
this so seriously i also referred it to
the cabinet office the cabinet office
propriety ethics team which also looked
at it for example to see whether action
was warranted on the ministerial code
they didn't they
they agreed that it didn't warrant that
so
although there was a complaint made
about uh inappropriate behaviour it did
not trigger the disciplinary action
either at the civil service level or the
cabinet office level in relation to the
code of conduct
so i not only followed it to the strict
letter i went beyond that and sought the
assurance why because i think it's so
important that people that make
complaints feel and can have the
confidence to come forward so it's the
proprietary and ethics team's fault that
he keeps that he continues on with this
list of
um inappropriate behavior at the very
least
i don't think anyone could say i was
blaming them um anyone what i wanted to
make sure is that there was proper
assurance and integrity around the
process because that's so important um
there's a load of you know what
westminster's like there's a whole rumor
mill but when you get a specific
complaint important that that's handled
rigorously robustly and fairly it again
i also make the point that the
individual concerned wanted to continue
working
with
chris pincher at the time and did not
want formal action taken
what about the foreign minister the
minister's now wife who made um her
comments in writing in 2017 when she
worked at troy central office
well i i can't speak to that i don't
know about that but of course that was
under the previous prime minister
yeah but she the prime minister must
have known
you suggest are you suggesting that that
uh carrie then um simmons now johnson
never spoke to her prime minister
husband about the behavior of this man
no that wasn't what i was suggesting i
don't know the facts of it what i was
saying is that the reappointment of
chris pincher back in 2017
following
complaints to be made about him at the
time followed a process an independent
process conducted by qc which did not
uphold the claims made against him and
his reappointment as a minister at that
time was obviously under the previous
government and the previous prime
minister those are the facts as i know
them okay talk to me about what downing
street we're telling a junior minister
bless him yesterday will quince this is
what he said to us on the show yesterday
it's going to be in this screen
i spoke with number 10 both yesterday
and today and i asked them firmly and
clearly for an answer on this and i've
been given categorical assurance that
the prime minister was not aware of any
serious specific allegation with regards
to uh the former deputy chief whitman
is that true
yeah i don't think the the look
i don't think the prime minister is
aware of any substantiated complaints to
the extent that they would trigger a
formal mechanism and as i said and
there's a distinction between the rumor
mill of westminster and complaints that
either result in a formal process
or a formal sanction yeah but the prime
minister we heard from downing street
what three hours later saying that four
hours later the prime minister was aware
of allegations that were either resolved
or did not progress to a formal
complaint as a lawyer i mean can you
tell me the difference between those two
points yeah the difference is a
complaint that is made that is of uh
where there's the uh evidence and it's
of the severity where former dis formal
either disciplinary action is taken
which is something which would happen in
all professional walks of life in or in
addition uh triggers mechanisms for
example and the ministerial code of
conduct and so the allegations that
we're talking about had not reached that
level and that's precisely what i the
account i think i've just given you
fairly and squarely about what happened
in october of 2019. so just to clarify
not aware of specific allegations is
what the minister sat there and said he
checked with number 10 they said to say
not aware of specific allegations four
hours later aware of allegations that
were resolved or did not progress to a
formal complaint that is dancing on the
head of a pin
i don't think it is i think we'll from
what i just uh understood talked about
specific and serious allegations and i
think there's a distinction between
something which is either not of the
severity or isn't resolved informally
and something which clearly does trigger
a formal disciplinary action or formal
sanction and i think most people would
understand that that is a fair and
reasonable distinction to draw but
there's a pattern of behavior isn't
there 2012 2013 2017 2019 september 2019
2021 october 2021 december 2021
june 2022
is that really somebody who is an
appropriate person to be um laying down
the law as deputy chief whip well you've
just read out a list of dates
and i don't know what each one referred
to but all i can say is where there's
been a credible complaint made they've
been followed up whether it was uh by me
in the foreign office or in 2017 there
was a qc that conducted uh the process i
think that's right there is a rumor mill
in westminster and i think it's
important both for the confidence of
victims but also fairness that you have
independent processes and i think that's
absolutely i mean what you're
complaining about is that we've been too
loyally and done it too much
but i think it is important to be
absolutely uh rigorous and and
scrupulously go by the book um and of
course in relation to chris pincher's
appointment as deputy chief whip the
cabinet office proprietor and ethics
team did not raise an objection to that
appointment we rely on these independent
processes because they're capable of
commanding the trust of those with which
we work and that is the crucial thing in
all this case i wonder where the bar is
though how high are we setting or lower
setting this bar well i don't think it's
right there just because there's a rumor
and gossip someone loses their job i do
think of course not no i do think it is
right that when there a complaint is
made it is properly investigated and
then you know is it serious enough is it
credible enough to want formal action
whether it's disciplinary under the
ministerial code i think that's the
right bar to set okay so when you were
his boss yeah um you were completely
happy with his behavior you say that you
pulled him to one side on one occasion
yeah why was that because of the you
know the complaint that was made um what
was the complaint i just because i'm
respecting the confidentiality of the
processes and those involved i don't
think it's right for me to go into that
i know why you ask the question what i
would just say is
i spoke to in no uncertain terms i have
to say
and this is no excuse this is no uh
mitigation but if you're asking me my
sense is that chris princher was
actually an exceptional minister and
very well regarded and it's interesting
and this sometimes is the case with
inappropriate behavior it's interesting
that the complainant that came forward
did not want formal action taken now it
can be for all sorts exactly
i'm agreeing with you as we know and
that is why i totally agree and that is
why that relationship between ministers
and the civil servants who do such a
fabulous job for us needs to be
protected and that is precisely why i
went and asked the cabinet office to
look at it again to check that the
judgment of the civil service was right
but
i don't know what to say to you because
because no action was taken against him
you say there wasn't enough evidence
because uh someone didn't want to press
that further for whatever reason they
might have been anxious they might have
been concerned
you have an independent process is also
to check regardless of what the
complainant says whether it is of a
severity that would warrant disciplinary
action but it looks as though it went on
and on and on even to the extent where
last week last middle of last week um he
was groping allegedly two men at the
carlton club people watching what was
going on well the minute that complaint
was made
he resigned himself he i don't think he
had any choice and the whip was removed
pending a formal investigation under the
grievance and complaints procedure of
the house of commons that is the correct
way to handle that allegation what did
the pm actually know do you think
i'm sure you must have talked about at
which point in time i i talked i've
talked him through um
in recent days what happened in
um uh
2019 um
my sense is but again um uh i i can't
speak for uh
exactly what the prime minister knew but
my sense is that he would have been
aware when uh the wire was tripped into
formal disciplinary action or let alone
a formal sanction
but of course we're constantly i mean
westminster is awash with gossip rumor
and i think it is right to draw that
question about what happened with you
what in 2019 when you had to let's say
discipline him you say talk to him he
wasn't displaying action it's very
important to draw that so when you had
to speak to him firmly did you then
subsequently tell the prime minister
about it no and i wouldn't expect to in
relation to something that fell below
the bar of disciplinary action what i
did do was inform the chief whip because
i do think it's important that we keep a
proper record and i referred it to the
cabinet office propriety and ethics team
because i wanted the assurance and
that's not to say that i disagreed with
the view of the permanent secretary or
the civil service but because i attached
such importance
to those around and those who work with
us having the confidence in the
processes which are there to protect
them it's very important and i take that
incredibly seriously the fda and
prospect unions they represent about a
thousand parliamentary workers um they
say that parliament is an unsafe place
to work because potentially of people
like this
well that's why we've got the new
processes in place an independent
grievance and complaint process and we
need to vest them with the power and the
confidence to do their job in the
relation to chris pincher that's exactly
what's happening okay um
talk to me about what should happen to
him now
well i think if you've got an
independent process
it's right to allow them to conduct
their investigation and then depends on
the outcome and i'm not going to get
ahead of that
he's an auditory mp he's had the whip
removed suspended pending that
investigation that's the right thing i
do also think when you've got a formal
mechanism like this you've got to
respect and not impinge on its ability
to conduct that investigation without
prejudice without prejudice when you
look back what would you have done
differently i've done exactly the same
again
even though
it appears
from this list that i've read to you i
don't need to go into all of the details
not least because there are children are
watching at this time in the morning but
back from
2012 through to 2022 that's a 10-year
period where it looks as though
he has potentially abused several people
on varying levels and that's the and
that's the luxury i was going to go on
to no i was going to go on to say given
that
should the police be investigating
well look you asked me what i could have
done should have done differently
i i think it's critically important to
have an independent process once the
civil service conducted i wanted the
reassurance of the cabinet office but
there was nothing
that was reported back to me that would
have warranted
disciplinary action let alone a police
investigation of course uh if i'd have
known something different a different
set of facts i would have acted on them
as quickly and as rigorously as i did
the complaint that i became aware of
okay it's good to talk to you just gotta
leave it there thanks very much indeed
thank you